In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinhaxadeon, from a first, on which we commemorate the Holy Prophet
Jeremiah.
On the first day of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Prophet Jeremiah,
sanctified and elect of God, even before his birth.
The Holy Prophet Jeremiah saw the light of day in about 650 BC, in the bosom of a priestly
family from Anathoth in the land of Benjamin.
From his earliest years, he was called by God to prophetic ministry.
As he hesitated, citing his youth and inexperience, the Lord touched his mouth, saying, Behold,
I have put my words in thy mouth.
He established him as a watchman, in order to proclaim to the people of Judah, hardened
in idolatry, the imminent threat of Assyrian invasion from the north.
As the mouth of God, with a firmness and daring which were not to fail him throughout his ministry,
Jeremiah reproached the King, princes, priests and false prophets for their apostasy and their
returning for help to the idols of foreign peoples.
He compared the people of God with an unfaithful wife, who had forgotten the love of the days
of her betrothal, when she walked through the desert behind her Lord.
As she refused to repent, she would be repudiated and given over, like a prostitute, into the hands
of the Assyrians, who would cover her in shame.
Behold, however, with compassion for his people, the prophet experienced in advance, in his
own person, the tribulations that were to come, and he cried out, My bowels, my bowels,
I am pained in my very heart.
My heart makeeth a noise in me, I cannot hold my peace.
Jeremiah was, in fact, not only the messenger charged with proclaiming divine decrees, but
prefiguring the mission of our Lord Jesus Christ.
He took his people's lot on himself and suffered for their salvation.
For many years he tirelessly passed on the divine oracles, either through words permeated
by majestic lyricism or through symbolic acts ordained by God, or, again, through his own
life and suffering, clear proclamations of the redemptive passion of Jesus Christ.
God once showed him, in a vision, a boiling pot, its mouth facing northwards, telling him
that it was from the north that trouble would flow down.
On another occasion he sent him to a potter working his wheel, who, when a pot was faulty, would
squash it down and make another of the clay.
As the clay is in the potter's hand, so are ye, in mine hand, a house of Israel," said
the Lord.
A prophet must be a sign, and this is why God forbade him to take a wife, and have issue
in that land given over to famine and the sword.
He also forbade him to go into a house where there was feasting, as he would silence the
songs of merriment and consolation.
He was going to withhold his grace and exile his people to a far country.
The prophet's whole life was therefore to be devoted to denouncing the vain hopes raised
by the people under the influence of false prophets, and to warn them of the coming catastrophe.
He also, though, preached that, in the distant future, the messianic reconciliation between
God and his restored people would be revealed.
From the very first years of his mission, Jeremiah came up against the scorn and mockery
of his fellow citizens, comparing his recalcitrant people to a vine whose grapes had been gathered
and was then s forth useless.
God then appeared to him and exhorted him to attempt once more to find even one grape
on a single vine.
One soul ready for conversion, but his efforts yet again received a setback.
A prophet is like a smith who proves the metal in the fire of the divine word and who must
finally make sure that rust does not eat away the metal so that it has to be scrapped.
In 612, the fall of Nineveh and the disintegration of the Assyrian Empire appeared to be a proclamation
of the liberation of the people's under its domination.
Three years later, the armies of Pharaoh Niko attempted to cross Palestine in order to fight
the Meeds and Persians.
Fearing dire consequences for his kingdom, King Josiah made great attempts to block their
passage, but he died in the battle of Meghido, leaving the kingdom of Judah an Egyptian
vassal.
Shortly after his victory, the Pharaoh was soundly beaten by Nebot Kinesar at Carcomish on
the Euphrates, and Palestine then fell under the Babylonian yoke.
This new situation seemed set to ruin all hope of religious and moral renewal aroused
by the reforms undertaken by King Josiah after the finding of the Book of the Law.
On the sovereign's death, the people fell back into injustice and moral perversion and turned
once again to the pagan cults of Baal and Malak, adding to them as an extra other Babylonian
gods and cults.
An external observance of the law, mixed with superstition and various magical practices,
was held to be enough.
In the face of this critical situation, Jeremiah, after twelve years of silence, spoke again
in public in the temple court on the anniversary of the King's enthronement.
He stood against the people's insensitive trust in the temple, which had become a den of thieves
and proclaimed its coming destruction through the wrath of God if the Jews refused to repent.
In a concerted impetus of rage, the priests, the false prophets, and the people seized hold
of the prophet and took him before the King to be condemned to death for blasphemy against
the temple.
He was released but was thenceforth pursued by the tenacious hatred of the priests and false
prophets.
Finding himself surrounded by falsehood and trickery, Jeremiah sought indiscouragement to
withdraw to a hut in the desert, far from this adulterous people that went from crime to
crime, refusing to be converted.
But confirmed by the word of God, which was for him the joy and rejoicing of his heart,
he did not abandon his mission but proclaimed to all and against all the imminent destruction
of the kingdom of Judah and the carrying off of its inhabitants.
This preaching provoked such opposition that in Anathoth itself, his hometown, the priests
and some members of his family tried to poison the prophet who was given over to them, like
a lamb that is brought to the slaughter.
Left alone, collubniated by his compatriots and deprived of all consolation, Jeremiah lifted
up a cry of distress to God and the Lord answered him.
They shall fight against thee, but they shall not prevail against thee, for I am with thee
to save thee and deliver thee.
At God's command, he broke a pitcher at the east gate, proclaiming that the siege of the
city was imminent, and that the valley down below would be called the valley of slaughter.
When he repeated the same message in the temple court on a feast day, the priest, Pashur,
chief of the temple police, struck the man of God and then had him put in an iron collar.
Freed in the morning, Jeremiah only continued to preach the more strongly.
He was forbidden further axes to the temple and spies were sent everywhere that he preached
to overhear his words.
The Caldean's victory over Egypt at Carcamish was, for the prophet, a chance to underline
the imminence of the danger and to renew his calls for repentance.
He then dictated to Baruch his scribe an oracle from the Lord and sent him to read the scroll
in the temple before the assembled people.
In the King heard of this, he read the scroll and progressively tore it up and burned it,
and ordered the arrest of Jeremiah and Baruch, but the latter managed to hide and evade their
pursuers.
After several years of submission to Nebukhides, King Jehoyakim revolted, provoking a punitive
expedition by the Babylonians that ravaged the lands of Judah.
The following year, Nebukhides himself laid siege to Jerusalem.
Three months later, the city fell to the Caldeans and the new young king, Jehconia, was exiled
to Babylon with his mother, the nobles, and ten thousand of the people.
In spite of this catastrophe, the people who remained in Jerusalem did not reform their depraved
behavior, and the false prophets continued to entertain the hope of a quick return by
the exiles and a triumphant revolt.
When onvoys of the neighboring peoples went to Jerusalem to negotiate a new coalition against
the Caldeans, with Zedukhia, the new king of Judah, Jeremiah appeared in public, weighed
down with a yoke and chains, and sang in the name of the Lord.
The nation and kingdom, which will not put their neck under the yoke of the king of Babylon,
that nation will I punish with the sword and with the famine and with the pestilence.
Sometime later, the false prophet Hananiah went to the temple, lifted the yoke from Jeremiah's
neck, and broke it, saying that the exiles would return after two years, and God would
break the yoke of the king of Babylon.
By God's inspiration, Jeremiah denounced Hananiah's mendacity, predicted his coming death and
proclaimed that the wooden yoke that had been broken would be replaced by yokes of iron.
Zedukhia refused to enter into the coalition and sent emissaries to Babylon to testify to his
loyalty. These onvoys carried a letter from Jeremiah to the exiles, telling them that,
at the end of their exile, which was to last for seventy years, God would be reconciled with them,
and would let himself be found by those who sought him with all their heart, and that exiles from
the kingdoms of Israel and Judah would enter again into the promised land with cries of joy.
God would once again gather his scattered sheep and would make a new covenant with his people,
one that was to be spiritual and eternal. I will put my law in their inward parts,
and write it in their hearts, and will be their God, and they shall be my people.
At the end of this period of calm, a new wave of insurrection began to trouble the kingdom of Judah
and the surrounding nations under the protection of Egypt, putting his trust in Egypt's promises
and in his capital's fortifications, Zedukhia refused to listen to Jeremiah's councils of
prudence and submission. Events developed a pace to confirm the prophet's fears. The Babylonians
arrived in sight of Jerusalem destroying everything in their path. In spite of the Egyptians'
help which allowed a short respite in the siege, the Babylonian armies quickly returned to the attack,
for a siege that was to bring about the ruin of Jerusalem. During the truce when Jeremiah left
the city in order to go and deal with part of his inheritance in the land of Benjamin,
he was arrested and accused of wanting to go over to the enemy,
buffeted by the soldiers and unable to justify himself, he was thrown into a damp, vaulted
cellar and subjected to ill treatment. The king summoned him in secret to question him about how
the siege would end, and the prophet told him in the name of God that he would be delivered into the
hands of the king of Babylon. Jeremiah was then shut in the guardhouse of the palace,
at the time that the caldians were resuming the siege. The city, being given over to famine
and epidemic, the princes told the king that the captive prophet was still discouraging the
people by telling them that only those who gave themselves up to the caldians would have their
lives preserved. With Zedukhia's agreement they seized hold of Jeremiah and cast him into a stinking
well, delivering him over to certain death. But an Ethiopian servant at court,
a bed malec, had compassion on his lot and persuaded the king to have him taken out.
Jeremiah remained in the guardhouse until the city was taken.
In July of 586 a breach was opened in the wall, and at the end of the following month,
Jerusalem, the proud, fell prey to the fury of the caldians.
Zedukhia attempted to escape, but he was captured by the enemy and taken before
Nebukhidnezer, who had his sons killed in front of him before blinding him and sending him into exile
in Babylon. The city and the temple were burned down, the wall demolished, the treasures
looted, and the greater part of the people deported, thus fulfilling Jeremiah's prophecies.
The aged prophet was freed from his chains and taken away with the captives.
It was on leaving behind him the burning city that we are told. He uttered his sublime
lamentations. Arriving in Rama, he was released and left free to go where he would.
Refusing to travel to Babylon, he preferred to go to Mikpah, to be near Godolayus,
to whom the government of the little remnant, which had not been exiled, was confided.
But after only two months, Godolayus was assassinated. The people, fearful of reprisals by the
caldians, then sought to flee to Egypt. In spite of Jeremiah's warnings that they should not
fear the king of Babylon but trust in God's protection, once again neither the officials nor
the people were willing to submit to God's word, and they left for Egypt. Unwillingly following the
refugees who had arrived in the Tachba Nez, the east of the Nile Delta, Jeremiah warned them
of Nebuchadnezzar's approaching invasion of Egypt, where he was once more to serve as the instrument
of divine wrath against his people's idolatry and hardness of heart. In 568 Nebuchadnezzar entered
Egypt, breaking down all the monuments of Egyptian worship and spreading death and destruction in his
wake. Only a small handful of Jews escaped to return to Palestine. According to an apocryphal
tradition, the prophet Jeremiah was then stoned by his fellow countrymen at Tophaz in Egypt.
Sealing with his death, the prophetic proclamation of him who would offer himself to death
for the salvation of all mankind. Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God
have mercy on us and save us.